despite controversies and legal
challenges the british government
has always insisted its arms licensing
rules
are robust and the courts have tended to
agree
we have one of the strictest arms
licensing
regimes in the world robust maybe
but are the laws as transparent as the
british government
would have us believe after extensive
research sky news has found
that the british government has no idea
exactly
how many weapons the uk is selling to
other countries
on top of that we have traced british
sniper rifles into the hands of russian
troops in ukraine
something which the british government
cannot explain
so we're going to lay out how we found
these guns
who is using them and why this is
important
this is a sniper rifle made by accuracy
international
a firearms manufacturer based in
portsmouth
they make top-of-the-range
military-grade sniper rifles
in 2015 the company was given a business
enterprise award
by the queen to be clear we're not
accusing
accuracy international of doing anything
wrong
but they are a good example of how the
system works
or you might say doesn't work
in a joint investigation with lighthouse
reports the guardian
and bellingcat sky news has found
examples
of accuracy international rifles being
used around the world
including by russian troops
we have worked alongside researchers
with extensive weapons identification
experience
to underpin our findings and it is all
in the detail
the easiest and surest way to identify a
gun is by locating
the serial number like in this picture
of the then russian president
dmitry medvedev by that we can tell that
he is using
an accuracy international arctic warfare
model
but that isn't always possible because
the serial number
simply isn't always visible so we looked
for other distinctive features
to help us identify a sniper rifle this
is the accuracy international
ax mc model as an example
take note of the receiver the stock
the handguard the barrel and the pins
[Music]
once we knew what we were looking for
the research team then
cross referenced our information with
pictures and videos of sniper rifles
around the world
to see how they're being used and by
whom
this video was shared by the ukrainian
military who claim
it was filmed in eastern ukraine in
february this year
although we can't verify that date
through their equipment and clothes
the figures appear to be russian special
operations soldiers
they're in the deserted village of
donetsky in the occupied luhansk region
of ukraine
how do we know that well we geolocated
the video using several identifiable
landmarks
like this wall the train lines and this
house
we found these distinctive landmarks on
google earth and we can confidently say
that they are in donetsky one of the
soldiers is holding a weapon
which appears to be a sniper rifle but
we can't see it clearly enough
to identify it in a longer separate
video of the same group
seen by sky news we can see the same
soldier
and the same rifle this time it is clear
enough to id
using the techniques that we described
earlier we believe that this is a
british-made
accuracy international rifle model
ax-338
we have compared this rifle to an image
in the manufacturer's official brochure
and we can identify these key
similarities
early in the clip we get a good view of
this person
from his social media account he appears
to be a russian soldier
or volunteer but we haven't been able to
fully verify this
so here we have a british-made sniper
rifle being used by
russian forces in eastern ukraine
but why does this matter well
russia is occupying this part of ukraine
and ukraine is an
ally of britain and crucially the
british government has told us
they have only ever allowed rifles to be
exported to russia
for commercial or sporting purposes
never
for use by russian forces and this isn't
the only time
that we have seen ai guns in the hands
of the russian military
this picture is from 2010 it shows a
rifle being used by a russian security
services sniper
on a gantry round the kremlin in moscow
[Music]
if we zoom in you can see those pins and
receiver
they match up with the ai arctic warfare
magnum model
here is another example this is a
russian security service training
exercise
from 2019 if we pause
here you can see two sniper rifles being
used
the weapon in the front is a modified
version of the axmc model
that we showed you earlier the stock is
from another accuracy international
rifle
the at-308 so we have traced
uk-made rifles into the hands of russian
forces
but accuracy international the
manufacturers say that they
haven't sold any weapons to russia since
the year 2000s
and in 2014 the eu put an arms embargo
on moscow
well it is concerning and it shows the
complexity of the
international arms trade you normally
associate proliferation of small weapons
with non-staked actors with
tribal conflicts with terrorism
extremism or indeed drug smuggling
people trafficking and so forth
but here we have a state that has an
arms embargo against it
now using weapon systems that are
designed and procured
here in the uk now big questions whether
this as you suggest
were part of a trade deal prior to 2014
or indeed have been exchanged via a
third party
and that's the piece that concerns me
whether we've actually exported these
in good faith to another country who
have then exported them again
to russia to be used in these situations
it all comes down to how the uk
exports these weapons which is
mind-bogglingly complicated
but bear with us to sell things like
rifles
tear gas and tanks a company needs
an export license a permit if you like
they broadly fit into two categories
standard and open standard licenses
contain
lots of detail including how much the
items are worth
this can then give a clue as to how many
rifles for example are being sold
but open licenses tell you much less
basically just the type of item and
which country it is going to
and here is the important part open
licenses do not give an indication
of how many items are being sold so it
could be
five rifles five thousand rifles or even
five hundred thousand rifles so if the
government doesn't know precisely how
many weapons are being exported
how can it say with confidence that its
licensing process
is robust and transparent to put this
into
some sort of context an estimate done by
the government
into the amount of money raised by arms
sales
has it that as much as 50 come
from open licenses so we asked the
government for clarification
on how many weapons are sold abroad
and they said they don't have that data
they simply
don't record it the use of open license
is extremely concerning it removes a lot
of transparency from the process which
is already very secretive
it means that we don't really know how
many weapons are
being sold we don't really know how many
weapons are being exported
and if we don't have that basic
information to begin with then we can't
hold the government to account with it
the government says its laws around arms
sales
are strict and robust and yet
we have found british-made rifles in the
hands
of russian forces and nobody seemingly
can explain how they got there
i can say as a former foreign minister
and defense minister that we do have
very vigorous licensing systems in place
but as this exposes
we do need to look at this again
you